good afternoon I'm joined today by
Professor Steven house national medical
director of NHS England and Sara album
who is a chief executive of the Health
and Safety Executive first I want to
update you on the latest data on the
corona virus response two million seven
thousand one hundred and forty six tests
for Korea device have now been carried
out in the UK including eighty five
thousand two hundred and ninety three
tests cat out yesterday two hundred and
twenty six thousand four hundred and
sixty three people have tested positive
that's an increase of three thousand
four hundred and three cases since
yesterday eleven thousand six hundred
and five people are currently in
hospital with corona virus up from
eleven thousand four hundred and sixty
five the previous day and sadly of those
tested positive for corona virus across
all settings thirty two thousand six
hundred and ninety two have now died
that's an increase of six hundred and
twenty seven fatalities since yesterday
this is of course devastating news for
families across the United Kingdom and
we all need to stay alert and control
the virus I just want to remind people
of the details of next phase of our
fight against corona virus that we sent
out this week return to the first slide
in order to monitor our progress we are
establishing a new co vyd alert level
system with five levels each relating to
the threat at to the level of threat
posed by the virus the alert level will
be based primarily on the r-value and
the number of corona virus cases an
intern that alert level will determine
the level of social distancing measures
in place the lower the level the few of
the measures the higher the level the
stricter the measures the show social
distancing measures remain critical
in our efforts to control the virus
throughout the period of lockdown which
started on master 23rd we have been at
level four meaning a curve in nineteen
evident general circulation and
transmission is high or rising
exponentially but thanks to the hard
work and sacrifices the British people
in this lockdown you have helped to
bring the our level down and we are now
in a position to begin moving to level
three in careful steps as you'll see on
the next slide we have set out the first
of three steps we will take to carefully
modify the measures gradually ease the
lockdown and begin to allow people to
return to their way of life but
crucially whilst avoiding what would be
a disastrous second peak that overwhelms
the NHS after each step we will closely
monitor the impact of that step on the
are and the number of infections and all
the available data and we will only take
the next step when we are satisfied that
it is safe to do so
step one from this week those who cannot
work from home should now speak to their
employer about going back to work you
can now spend time outdoors and exercise
as often as you like you can meet one
person outside of your household outside
provided you stay two metres apart step
two from June the 1st at the earliest as
long as the data allows we aim to allow
primary schools to reopen for some
pupils in smaller class sizes
non-essential retail to start to reopen
when and where it is safe to do so
cultural and sporting events to take
place behind closed doors without crowds
and then step three no earlier than July
the fourth and again if only the data
says it is safe we aim to allow more
businesses and premises to open
including potentially those offering
personal care such as leisure facilities
public places and places of worship many
of these businesses will need to operate
in new ways to ensure they're safe and
we will work with these sectors on how
to do this as you'll see from slide 3
having taken the first step in carefully
adjusting some of the measures and our
advice to people on what to do
we have also updated our messaging we
are now asking people to stay alert
control the virus and save lives
yes staying alert for the vast majority
of people still means staying at home as
much as possible but there a range of
other actions we're advising people to
take people should stay alert
by working from home if you can limiting
contact with other people keeping
distance if you go out 2 meters apart
where possible washing your hands
regularly wearing a face covering when
you're in an enclosed space where it is
difficult to be socially distant for
example in some shops and on public
transport and if you or anyone your
household has symptoms you all need to
self isolate a slide for shows if
everyone stays alert and follows the
rules we can control coronavirus by
keeping the are down and reducing the
number of infections that is how we can
continue to save lives and livelihoods
as we begin as a nation to recover from
coronavirus and to underpin this in the
workplace we have published new kovat 19
secure guidance on working safely
available to UK employers across eight
work settings which are allowed to be
open and where their employees cannot
work from home this also includes
guidance for shops which we believe may
be in a position to begin a phase
reopening at the earliest from the 1st
of June firms unions industry bodies and
the devolved administration's
have all fed into this guidance to give
businesses and their employees the
confidence they need to work safely and
I believe we have reached a consensus in
doing that we've also worked with public
health England and the Health Safety
Executive to develop best practice on
the safest ways of working across the
economy the guidelines outlined
practical steps for employers to take
including carrying out a curve it 19
risk assessment in consultation with
employees or trades unions a
downloadable notice is included in the
documents which employers should display
in their workplace to show employees
customers and other visitors that they
have followed the guidance we've also
provided practical steps for employers
to consider such as putting up barriers
or screens and shared spaces creating
fixed teams or partnering to minimize
the number of people in contact with one
another and frequent cleaning of work
areas and equipment between uses to
reduce transmission to support employers
and employees through this the
government has made available up to an
extra 14 million pounds for the Health
and Safety Executive equivalent to an
increase of 10 percent of their budget
this is for extra call center employees
inspectors and equipment if needed we
also know how important the job
retention scheme has been in helping
businesses through this difficult time
and today the Chancellor has announced a
four-month extension of the scheme to
help provide certainty to businesses to
date seven and a half million jobs have
been furloughed protecting the
livelihoods across the nation until the
end of July there will be no changes to
the scheme then from August to October
the scheme will continue for all sectors
and regions of the UK but with greater
flexibility to support the transition
back to work employers currently using
the scheme will be able to bring
employees back part-time and as the
economy reopens
we will ask firms just
sharing with government the cost of
paying people's salaries to be clear the
same level of support of 80 percent of
people's current salary up to two and a
half thousand pounds will continue to be
met but through a shared effort between
employers and government we'll be
setting out more details on the changes
before the end of the month throughout
this pandemic I have been struck by the
way people have looked out for one
another
these measures are produced in that
spirit so employers I say use this
support and guidance to know you're
doing the right thing and work with your
unions and workers to keep each other
safe out of workers I say we are looking
out for you we want you to feel
confident that you are financially
supported and returning to a safe
workplace because in this time like no
other we all need to work together
safely as we rebuild our economy